[Applaudissements]
le conseil de classe le voir et c'est
juste après bien entendu on aura le jeu
at the mac sur koh lanta les shérifs the
voice c'était samedi soir sur tf1
présenté par notre nikos aliagas qu'on
embrasse 6ème épisode des auditions à
l'aveuglé
tf1 est arrivée en tête des audiences un
damien canivet 5,1 millions de
téléspectateurs ils sont calés autour de
5 millions de téléspectateurs
ce vol ce qui est en tête justement
meurtre en lorraine comme vous l'a dit
avec stéphane bern dans ce huitième
magasin pas et le combat des chefs et
orient-extrême orient-express
orient-extrême c'est un restaurant le
voyage d'une légende c'est ce que
j'appelle puisque je suis plus souvent
sur arte que sur les autres chaînes vous
le savez est d'ailleurs oui non mais
j'adore quelques personnes à regarder
leur contexte rennais c'était génial
minable se serait fait passer un samedi
soir comme vous mais génial non bassila
regarder henry pourrait plaire alors on
va voir déjà la prestation de tania qui
a bouleversé jennifer vous êtes sorti en
larmes du plateau on va voir l'extrait
vous allez me dire pourquoi c'est vrai
que c'est c'est fou on vous a jamais vu
comme ça
regardez
[Musique]
combien méritée
je les vois
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
alors jennifer vous avez vous êtes
sortie du plateau on la remet elle a
rejoint votre équipe pourquoi c'est pas
ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé notionnels
mans c'était très fort de voir la mère
et la fille de venir se présenter sur ce
plateau qe2 voice toutes les émotions
comme ça à débordement la sincérité
qu'elle avait dans leurs démarches le
fait qu'elle lui passe le flambeau et
puis ce répertoire ça m'évoque aussi des
souvenirs d'enfance
j'ai vu ma grand-mère en negrita quoi
enfin j'ai l'apparition de ma grand mère
ça m'a fait quelque chose sincèrement et
du cou du coup oui je suis abstenu de
pleurer devant elle quand même ça ne les
concernaient des sentiments un petit peu
enfouis qui sont qui ont ressurgi
donc je je suis sortie du plateau j'ai
repris l'air et puis donc je n'ai pas
encore vu le replay j'étais sur scène
samedi soir donc si vous êtes heureux
qu'elle ait rejoint d'autres équipes
oui je suis très heureuse je suis très
heureux je suis très heureuse d'être
témoin de tous ces beaux talents en fait
qui viennent si vous vous régaler encore
dont évoluent en sincèrement c'est
vraiment une belle aventure humaine
alors on va voir les notes que vous avez
mis à ce vote sur dadt est très bonne
pour la plupart après il y en a trois
plus mauvaises alors on va voir déjà un
candidat qui a beaucoup fait parler sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est théophile
régner il a gagné ce brave belgique en
2010 fait
regardez sa prestation j'ai participé à
nouveau une belgique en 2017
quand on n'a que l'amour
pour tracer un chemin mais de semaine en
semaine j'étais plébiscité par le public
et j'ai fini par gagner ce soir je viens
remettre mon titre en jeu et je cherche
pas de légitimité cherche surtout à me
dépasser que c'est ça qui me stimule en
fait
ce soir je rentre seul comme hier
avant-hier l'impression que le monde le
regarde de travers
j'ai plein la paix les conseils que de
donner mon père regarde à gauche et à
droite juste avant tu traverses où il
veut
[Applaudissements]
m
mon goût
[Applaudissements]
il ya deux jours par exemple qui dit
dans la rubrique foutage de gueule on a
maintenant le recyclage d'anciens
vainqueurs de the boys dans des pays
voisins et qui n'ont rien fait depuis
gilles verdez émis 1 pourquoi notamment
pour ça que moi alors j'ai trouvé
l'émission de samedi soir soporifique
mais je trouve que le casting pour moi
il est je vais employer un mot fort mais
il est honteux parce qu'on récit qui
combat les les cotes ne t'ai jamais sur
sept c'est exact jennyfer on recycle un
gagnant de ce box belgique alors alors
fait une mise en lumière quand même pour
ce talent qui a effectivement gagné 2
vols/semaine on n'était pas au courant
du coach on n'est pas au courant
j'imagine entendu on découvre des
talents même temps bien sûr à ce moment
là on peut reprendre
kenji tous les anciens vainqueurs oui
bah oui mais c'est pareil pas non une
envie d'un tremplin supplémentaire pour
démarcher justement et se servir d'une
grande vitrine qu'est devenu ce pourquoi
pas moi je trouve ça très étonnant de
reprendre des gens ce ne sont plus les
amateurs c'est des gens confiait aussi
adrien une voix il ya eu un adrien
professionnels qui est un habitué des
comédies musicales aussi sur twitter ça
a réagi so lu ment
regardez
[Musique]
et les antilles justement vous êtes vous
oui
voilà à rien alors les blocs je voudrais
une bonne note la dame nakany baez et
1908 parce que alors moi je trouve que
c'était me simplement formidable
contrairement à certaines marques de tf1
comme danse avec les stars qui ont
tendance à ronronner moi je trouve que
cette émission après huit saisons n'a
pris aucune ride et les coachs sont
percutants charismatique la production
et je suis pas du tout d'accord avec toi
gilles me revient toujours à nous
dénicher des personnalités atypiques on
a vu les honneurs winter notamment cette
saison qui est la première drag queen à
part ça vous dérange de voir des talents
comme voilà sept personnes qui gagnent
en belgique où adrien qui est un habitué
des comédies musicales ou pas du tout
pas du tout moi en tant que
téléspectateur qu'est ce que j'ai envie
de voir quand je regarde les gens qui
alors ému j'ai envie de voir la chanson
j'ai envie de voir des beaux moments que
la personne ait fait the voice en
belgique qu'est ce que ça peut faire
jeune habitat en belgique j'ai pas envie
de jouer comme on en croise d'ailleurs
tous les belges qui nous regardent et si
vous habitiez en belgique souriez très
heureux que j'adore les prix sont plus
d'accord j'adore les frites d'accord
vous n'aimez pas d'humour
je voudrais alors doc gynéco qui met 7
c'est important votre avis sur the voice
by bien c'est surtout et qu'il y a quand
même des professionnels de la musique et
qui savent entend répondre une oreille
moi j'ai trouvé que jennifer à son aise
moi je suis ce qu'elle dit et ce qu'elle
fait d'accord quand elle se retourne
c'est que c'est bon ben c'est le concept
de l'émission
[Rires]
je vole soit voir ses crocs dans lotus
quand il trouve un mot c'est que c'est
bon fils voit dans ce cas là alors on va
décrié tous les tous les concepts
voilà bah bravo en tout cas très bonne
chimie mohammed alors avant qu'on voit
votre 2 et pourquoi il y avait il y
avait deux des talents y avait beaucoup
de talent samedi soir notamment
il y avait une fille qui agite a
beaucoup fait parler c'est estelle
estelle a marqué les téléspectateurs
elle est passionnée elle chante
habituellement dans le métro ou dans la
rue et al hilal se retrouvent sur le
plateau de the voice elle vivait un rêve
regardez
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ouais
alors valu deux on va voir les deux
autres talents aussi qui ont retenu
l'attention
oui alors oui même si les audiences sont
bonnes je trouve que le concept
s'épuisent au fil des années et que le
fait qu'ils aient d'un candidat
gréements de belgique qui viennent
prouve qu'on recherche pas forcément à
créer des chanteurs on cherche juste à
faire une émission de divertissement à
ces salaires aussi oui mais alors soit
on est dans ce cas là on accepte de le
dire que c'est pas pour créer un nouveau
talent créer des nouveaux chanteurs et
je suis un petit peu dérangé parfois
quand même quelques-uns
quand on l'a on ramène des personnes qui
ont déjà une existence comme s'il n'y
avait pas de nouveaux talents en france
comme si on pouvait pas aller un peu
plus loin pour pousser au bout duquel sa
vie à pleines mains terre moi il ya des
moments alors je ne doute pas du monde
sa sincérité et d'émotion que vous avez
eue mais quand j'entends parfois des
chanteurs alors je n'ai pas l'oreille
musicale et chantée de façon plutôt
classique ou rien d'extraordinaire je
vous sens bouleversé transportés par
l'émotion comme si il faisait quelque
chose extraordinaire et que vous ne vous
retournez pas j'ai l'impression que
c'est un peu hypocrite et que c'est un
peu du cinéma et ça ça me dérange c'est
pour ça que j'ai du mal à dire l
émission alors gravir les passagers
objectif maintenant après c'est vrai
qu'on s'est selon ce qu'on reçoit etc
des avis très personnel effectivement on
est quatre coachs quatre coachs
différents réunis par la même passion
qu'est la musique en l'occurrence avec
notamment grâce à nos talents il ya des
voies de tout horizons confondus de tous
genres confondus tout âge confondu etc
selon ce qu'on reçoit en fait c'est bien
le moment et l'humeur et tout ce qu'elle
dégage cette voie là vient du haut que
c'est rare qu'est aussi beaucoup sescam
talk ils ont tellement plus à soprano
qui lie la rejoint sur scène pour
chanter avec eux vous vous avez l'air
content vous avez mis 1
c'est ça c'est m quelques rares membres
dont celui là regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toujours en train de montrer qu'il est
en train de mettre éclate alors les
membres du cercle
j'ai un bon set parce que j'aime bien
quand les gens qui viennent il chante
super bien ils sont super bons en bloc
sur un mec qui a fait the voice en
belgique il ya combien de kilos
candidats qui passent là qui vont
rejoindre les équipes des profs pour un
mec qui a fait the voice en belgique les
ja d'avitech à chanter formidable moi je
suis resté bluffé sur lui il ya anne
sophie da petite anne-sophie qui avait
une voix de dessins animés j'adore aussi
comme l'a chanté
camille qui était sélectionnée dans le
public moi j'écoute la radio toute la
journée toute la journée j'écoute la
radio dans le camion et bien si vous
vous dire qu'il chante cent fois mieux
que les tocards qu'on écoute la journée
à la radio
vous me dire à couper la radio la radio
voilà il vous êtes un petit rush pour
julien clerc et moi j'aime bien julien
clerc aussi parce que je trouve que ça
fait frais quand je le vois je suis
content qu'il soit là ça mais une
crédibilité en plus ça mais un taulier
et quand je quand je vois des gens dit
qui chante femmes jean louis qui je suis
content je me demande s'ils se retourne
alors une team qui se retourne jamais il
se retourne rarement julien car j'ai
l'impression qu'il a peur il est vrai
que c'est un manège dont il n'a pas
compris le bouton nadal a investi ici et
j'ai eu un accueil formidable m'emmerde
vous aimez vous pourquoi j'ai mis deux
parce que moi pour moi que je suis pas
d'attentes de nouveaux chanteurs de quoi
je prends ça comme un objet télévisuel
et malheureusement je suis entièrement
d'accord avec gide et jimmy mohamed et
surtout je trouve que l'arrivée de
soprano n'a rien changé au foot c'est
quand même à robin et permanent de
compliments d'émotion et on n'ose pas
dire les choses sans les chansons
il faut leur dire maintenant se retourne
pas on dit le paragraphe antastique
poutine accroche toi tes rêves
non quand il sur 3g que vous avez des
consignes jennifer là dessus est-ce que
vous avez des consignes des la nissim
deux jours bienveillant et faut être
honnête fait trouer mais alors elle
avait cette affaire et se prépare avec
son coeur mais sûrement il est super moi
je suis fan de lui il est vraiment
sincère et toujours comme ça c'est dix
ans il n'y a pas un coach caddie change
de métier arrête la musique mais non
mais non mais attendez là c'est une
bonne question pour dieu nous fait en
centrant talents et les 130
ils sont extrêmement bien non mais c'est
vrai que vous avez des consignes ou les
gens vous disent voilà il faut être un
peu bienveillant ou pas du tout de la
bienveillance
de toute façon rester de l'autre et puis
le respect par rapport au talent qui
vient ce parce que vous avez des
consignes de la production qui vous
disent voilà dans ce vol ce gala est
aveugle rappelle à l'époque la nouvelle
star le jury pouvait être très cinglant
avantage de rendre et manoukian dove
attia
balladur on vous dit non il faut être
assez gentil en fait on ne dit rien
ouais ils sont il ya une notion des
clips en fait malgré la grosse
machinerie chellah moi c'est pour ça que
je suis reparti dans cette aventure là
je saurais je serais incapable de mesut
m'exécuter à des à des règles ou des
accords des plex naturel
tout le monde est naturel tournée
d'adieu en déconner à ce même pas
retourner sur sa copine des sont fait
plaisir tout à l'heure c'était pour
déconner des connaissances plus la durée
vous voulez me faire belle mentalité
avec la fatigue on va voir ce qu'en
pensent les téléspectateurs tiens est-ce
que the voice s'il vous plaît the voice
non non on se réjouit aussi détendu
qu'il ya choqué pas choquer voilà les
gens veuillent un peu le dernier épisode
de zoé sur tf1 j'ai maté j'ai zappé à
73% et pourtant il était par 5,1
millions de téléspectateurs à regarder